foreign
that's going to drop any sort of
Bombshells today
not not for land
she's not from Miami oh Mary yes you yes
you are you have to own that what you
had together is over now okay let's put
a period at the end of it
[Music]
what is going on everybody this is John
with the Dr John baloney show so glad
that you're with us
listen if you want to be on the greatest
mental health in marriage and parenting
podcast ever and by the way we talk
about more than marriage and parenting
kind of whatever's going on in your life
exercise working out school systems
whatever work whatever you got I'm here
for you man I'm here and I'm grateful to
the millions of people that download
this this uh podcast every month and to
those of you who are sharing with your
friend I'm just so grateful if you want
to be on the show shoot me an email at
John deloney.com ask that's
j-o-h-n-d-e-l-o-n-y
dot com slash ask ask fill out the
little form and it goes right to Kelly
and Jenna Kelly will just hit delete
automatically just because that's how
she rolls and Jenna will read it and
then she will curl up in a ball and weep
for a while and then she'll call you
back or you can go um to
1-844-693-3291 and give us a buzz and be
on
the show hey we uh had a session last
yesterday
Kelly me Jenna going through the
feedback of the show and I'm I was
stunned I thought there'd be like seven
people need to be all mad I was stunned
by how many people wrote in with your
feedback here's some ideas out for the
show here's some thoughts we have
um and so great I'm so grateful for it
um yeah I just want to say thank you and
you'll see some of those things
implemented as we move forward whether
it was show ideas show topics or what if
baloney what if you just toned it down
at the beginning of the show and didn't
yell and scream at everybody in the
community and here's what's so strange I
know this I'm not like a loud Yeller guy
anybody who hangs out with me knows like
I'm pretty chill
I can be intense but pretty chill I
don't know why I just feel the need to
yell every time the show music comes on
it's like so that guy's done we're done
with that we're just gonna have regular
conversation time and we'll still have
fun and probably the horse noises will
return all right so in this first call
um Jenna is this is a a couple right yes
they're still married
yes but they're separated yes okay
married but separated so we're gonna
talk to them both and this is my
favorite because usually we just get to
talk to one and just hear one side of
the story and today we get both all
right so let's go out to James in Los
Angeles James you there
yeah how you doing John a big fan of
your show I'm I'm uh I was calm but now
that uh I hear the shows I'm kind of a
little nervous all right hey uh I don't
know what I'm doing either man so we're
all just gonna figure this one out so
I'm gonna bring on Mary right now Mary
you there
I'm here all right so James and Mary are
you all in the same house
yes I'm I'm in separate rooms okay so
before we get going this is a question I
always ask people when I'm sitting down
in this situation
um everybody's safe everybody good
everybody able to be honest
okay
and before we go one step further is
there anybody that's gonna drop any sort
of
Bombshells today
not not from my end
she's not from Miami oh Mary yes you
are okay listen Mary before you do you
gotta say hey remember when I said I
wasn't going to I'm good I'm going to
right now okay cool
no yeah no there's no bombs yes there is
I can tell okay awesome all right so uh
James you reached out you all have been
separated for a year and a half tell me
the story
um from the beginning right
um jump into the middle
okay
um I was not a loving uh husband
um I was like I've been listening to
your show for years so this helped me
tremendously tremendously I um I was
like what's up with people that you
explained one time that I could be
sitting in the couch and my kids and my
wife could feel the energy that I'm just
on top of them so it was that type of
environment uh never physical never
never like that but um uh I stopped
doing the cute things with her I wasn't
um I was when she would try to like make
love to me I was always not confident on
myself so I would be neglect
um
did you ever cheat on her
uh yes and I barely told her last week
after watching your show I got with my
pastor because I don't have I don't have
friendships or nothing and I'm working
on that and I got help and he actually
listened to the show and then and I told
her I told him I was like I'm all in
he's like well if you're all in you have
to get out the secrets out there and
then you got to tell her so I was trying
to do it and while there was a third
party but that that a couple days before
we're gonna meet up with that Pastor to
to me tell her um she asked me because
we're hanging out since we have kids
we're trying to get a surprise so we've
got a birthday gift for my baby she
asked me and um and I had it prepare for
then I told the past I was like hey if
she asked me before I don't want to lie
to her what I do is like you gotta be
honest and then whatever she asks you to
be honest so
um I did a cheat on her once um years
ago like maybe like 2019 around that
time okay and um it's been extremely
hard for me because I it's hard for me
to open up uh I don't know I never
before I didn't have the tools but
listening to you I started reaching out
to community pastors I'm fairly uh
really started running therapy and
everything so it's been helping me a lot
and uh and I one of your shows said if
you don't open up right now you're gonna
open up how you really feel you're gonna
live with a life full of regret so I was
like I want to lose my wife I want to
open up and um actually when uh when I
might where's where we live with split
so when I have my baby
um uh I've seen some messages on his
phone uh that she took pictures of of
conversations of people she was speaking
to and then I wanted them that she
actually slept with a guy while we're
separating so that thing Hit Me Harder
but in my mind I was already ready to
tell her so I'm like oh my God I'm
really losing my wife so uh
with a fire behind me to actually be
like I gotta open up regardless how hard
it is so um
um so so here's what I want to say
brother
um let's put the infidelity aside let's
put all the other stuff aside
okay I want to say
um
you are in very rare air
okay
air a i r you're in very rare hair and
if you were right here I would get up
from where I'm at I'd pull these dumb
headphones out of my ears and I'd I'd
give you a hug okay I'm proud of you
it made me want to cry because well no
no no no here's why here's why I don't
excuse what you did we got to get
through that stuff okay and I we haven't
heard Mary's side but what I do here
is a desperate man who has done a what I
think is a really hard thing
uh what's your what's your uh ethnic
background
I'm actually we're not Mexican okay
you're you're staring down Generations
you're staring into the future and
you're saying I want a different kind of
man in the mirror I want my kids to
experience a different kind of man I
want my wife to experience a different
kind of man and
um I want things to be different that's
a hard hard path to take and so I want
to tell you I'm proud of you that's hard
okay thank you cool
cool I really appreciate that's really
what I'm trying to I don't know that's
really what I'm all in for okay good for
you man it's it's tough it's tough it's
tough it's tough and you're you can be
an example to millions of men listening
to this thing right now okay all right
so Mary tell me your side
um
I'm just gonna say uh be so great if you
were like everything he just said is
full of crap here's what really happened
that'd be awesome but but go ahead
so
I guess a little backstory is that we
were a blended family so I came with
kids he has boys um and we have together
one little one which is six years old
how many in total um so five all
together okay are you still in contact
with their dad
um no so I was I'm a single mom to my
first two my oldest okay
um so
I mean there was obviously I'm not gonna
say everything was bad
um but a lot of the things you know his
attitude like the way he was towards us
it was just you know it made the whole
relationship a little hard
um can we say can we say can we say it
made the whole thing real hard
yeah okay let's don't minimize it okay
it was hard it was tough yeah it was
hard um you were you were a single mom
with now five kids
and yeah kind of a gigantic toddler with
an attitude problem right and I had it
yes and I had come from a domestic
violence relationship with my first
relationship so
um when I got pregnant right away I went
into the relationship with James and
I was five months pregnant when my mom
passed away she got killed by a drunk
driver
so apart from my relationship that was
another big thing that took a toll on me
um and then so I left because obviously
his attitude the way it was going and
then uh you know messages here and there
that I found of him talking to other
other women you know um and things I
would say please don't do this please
don't do that and he just he didn't care
um so I split from him and like you said
it's been a year and a half and I feel
like I'm finally at a place where I'm at
peace like I'm really happy I'm I'm at a
place where I'm I feel good
um and
when he saw obviously he said those
messages and he and I I asked questions
and he confessed to me that just opened
a whole other
I guess pain in my heart because
pain and Clarity because now I can look
back and say now it makes sense now you
weren't crazy right that was a big one
because I really thought the whole
relationship was like what am I doing
wrong like why you know maybe I am crazy
because he would throw those comments
you're crazy you're crazy like what are
you talking about you know and now it's
like okay it makes sense and
that's that's kind of where I'm at right
now and so
is this phone call are y'all are you
interested in getting back together too
or are you are you you're obviously
going to be in a relationship with James
for a long time because you'll have a
kid together
um are you interested in in
um just having a like a good grown-up
adult friendship with somebody that you
share a child with but you want to move
on with your with your life because I
hear from James
I mean James you said I don't want to
lose my wife and I realize oh man she's
she is
seeking out
um physical and emotional connection
with other men can add on to it please
yeah of course of course when we first
met uh I met her uh my job at warehouse
um so to me it was like love at first
sight like physically at least you know
like and then when I met her I was like
oh my gosh she's a Christian like I
always wanted a Christian woman anyways
um so after a meeting era the guy that
introduced us I ended up hearing rumor
that that she slept with him so I end up
confronting her I found this out after
like everybody found out that she was
pregnant that confessed her she's like
yeah like a month or two before so that
and then there was another guy that
always chase after her and she confessed
that she said with him too and then at
church she confessed I was like is there
anything else when she she confess one
more person so like coming in I was
already feeling uh like that so I feel
like I'm in the same boat right now
since I've seen those messages because
I'm like she's she's I'm starting the
same way as we started like she she she
came with sleeping with men like right
before so I was like hold on hold on I I
don't think it's fair to hold her
accountable for things that she did
before y'all were together
uh
okay well here's all I'm saying
those things
and you opted in
true and you knew those things and you
opted in and then you had a baby
together then y'all got married right
and so I also think and
you came in admittedly feeling less than
you already walked in the front door
carrying her Across the Threshold
comparing yourself to at least those
three guys
okay for sure so it's important that you
own both of it I opted into this deal so
I'm not gonna opt in and then just sit
there and complain about what I opted in
for okay and
you own your side which is man I
instantly felt comparison less than like
whoa like I I and most men feel that and
most men spend their lives puffing their
chest Out Swinging
um running from stuff numbing out or
blaming people and so for you to look in
the mirror and say no no I gotta own
that I felt less than that's a big huge
step okay
okay is that fair
yes thank you for that and then this
comes so
um Mary where are you are you interested
in getting back with James
um to be honest not at the moment okay
um
I I don't want to say okay because to be
honest this in December I filed for a
divorce okay
um and like I would say a month after
almost two was when he found the
messages and he came to me you know
saying hey let's work this out you know
and I was already you know out and now
I'm kind of like
I I feel like I could eventually maybe
give this another try
but I don't want to just jump back in
and say yeah I'm all in I think for him
it's easier to say I'm all in because he
was the one that messed up you know um I
I feel like I like I like I told him I'm
in a really good place right now and I
said I need if there is any ever ever a
chance again I said I need you to work
on yourself because
I know a lot of the the things he did to
me the you know a lot of his attitude
and everything I know it comes from like
trauma that he's had in his childhood or
things in his past and I told him I need
you to work on yourself because I'm
doing the same and I know I'm not
perfect obviously I I'm actually seeking
therapy right now
um because I've been through so many
things and it's like we can't you know
we both can't come to try and build a
healthy home happy home if we're not
healed ourselves enough absolutely all
right can I have two other two of course
you can
um since I've been listening to your
show I'm really like every day for a
year I've been forcing myself I'll grow
up single child since I was 12. I have
no memories uh sitting down in the
kitchen table my family the same parents
uh one brother told you like 11 years
apart no memories at all I got Rachel
babies hit her so I left home alone so I
always felt like a needle like love now
it's not as bad but I've been seeking
Health Therapy since a year two uh your
therapy barely maybe like two weeks ago
but but like actually like getting to me
with the pastors and he's a counselor
and all that for years so I've been like
letting myself uh as a person I need a
lot of work obviously but um that's my
question too for you is she's at her
best I've ever seen and I'm happy
because she's done a great job and and
to me I want my family back so it's like
if she does give me a try I wanna I
wanna I wanna bring I want to lift her
up I want to be something
uh I I I want you know what I'm saying
something I got you I got you
um all right so I'm gonna I'm gonna talk
to YouTube but I'm also gonna use this
as an opportunity to talk to a broader
audience
the last number I heard was 50 percent
50 of couples coming into some sort of
marriage counseling or dealing with
infidelity
okay and so I tell you all that to not
make it an excuse but to let you know
that um y'all aren't by yourself in this
deal okay
and it's very common for one person to
be out I'm done
or I like the healing that's happening
in my life right now and let me give
give you some different language maybe
For the First Time Mary in a long time
you feel safe your body feels at peace
right like your shoulders drop when you
walk into your apartment or into your
house
you're not worried about whether you're
gonna get hit you're not worried about
whether there's going to be a
radioactive guy on the couch whether
you're gonna get bombarded with five
different kids like so your body feels
safe and James
for the first time in a long time you're
making connections that probably men in
your in your family line have never made
which is for sure I have a body that is
starved for connection the worst the way
to torture James is to withhold love
because that happened your whole life
right
very perfectly safe and so as a that's a
you can see how really quick we can get
into a pretty unhealthy dance where you
are almost demanding connection which
then and of itself isn't connection and
Mary has had people Force connection on
her for a long time and so her body
pulls away which then makes the alarms
and your body get louder and you get
closer and get more radioactive and she
almost will connect with you out of
Defense right so here's what we have to
do
you have to own that what you had
together is over now okay let's put a
period at the end of it James you're
going to drive yourself mad
trying to get back quote unquote what
you had
you're right I'm driving myself crazy
yeah you you drive yourself crazy and
Mary doesn't want what she had she likes
her life now and she's got peace finally
okay and so what we want to do and by
the way this is going to be helpful for
you too whether you just stay really
good friends who are great co-parents
with your kids and your kids by the way
deserve that okay yeah
um
what you have to work on moving forward
is we've got to create something
completely new
something where that probably neither of
you saw in your parents lives
that you probably all have never
experienced together which means we're
going to have to give each other a lot
of Grace
we're gonna have to get rid of the
victim mentality and the perpetrator
mentality we're both here okay
all right we're both together and now
what we're going to do is here's where
the healing is going to begin you both
know what you're capable of
you both know that you can lie to each
other that you can hide from each other
that you can tell each you all both know
that you both know you can keep deep
secrets from one another right
yes you both know that you can look each
other and say I'm in Forever are you in
forever I'm in forever and both of y'all
weren't in forever right so here's the
thing you both know that about each
other many many people never find the
depths of what they're capable of y'all
have
and what I would tell you and this is
going to sound crazy that is a powerful
place to start rebuilt rebuilding
something new from
that there's some deep intimacy shared
there I know what I'm capable of and you
know what you're capable of
let's sit down at the table here okay
and here's what it's gonna look like
moving forward
y'all got to come up with a language a
way that you talk to one another where
Mary is allowed to say
um no thank you
and James you're gonna have to feel that
in your body not as a rejection but as
Mary
standing up and letting her needs be
heard
because your body's gonna scream
rejection rejection rejection fight run
and you're gonna have to just simply say
no that's another adult that I love and
care about who loves and cares about me
who just doesn't want to go get coffee
tonight
yeah that's what I said I've been doing
that like my best uh like not take it as
rejection like you said my body reacts
to it good good good good now if you
James do a bunch of stuff if you change
a bunch of things in your life to quote
unquote get her back
that is that's a that's jet fuel and
it's Rocket Fuel inside of a a missile
it runs out it burns real hot and goes
real fast and it goes it burns out real
quick
yes you are gonna have to look in the
mirror and decide I'm worth being
healthy and well for James
yes and my promise is when you are
healthy and well for James which means
I'm going to keep talking to somebody
that I trust who's got experience in
training so I can get some of these
lessons I didn't learn at home growing
up I'm going to get a group of guys that
um not that we go you know run the town
with but that we hang out we do fun
stuff we watch the fights we we take
trips together we whatever we do right
we do life together we fix each other's
cars together whatever it is
and then you're going to present to Mary
a body that is not desperately trying to
use her to feel safe which in turn is
going to let her feel safe see what I'm
saying I understand it's hard
it's hard it is because I'm trying to
I'm trying to see how
um how to take away that oh I want to do
it for her as well but I want to like do
it for you to learn how to like do it
for me yes do it for you no one's ever
told you this man but you're worth it
thank you and I'm not saying that just
play Kate and if I was here I'd make it
really awkward I'd put my hands on on
either side of your face and I'd scare
you directly into your eyes okay I'd
make it real real weird man
but listen you're worth that and Mary
you're worth being safe and you're worth
feeling at peace
yeah right so yeah this is the launching
pad for what comes next Mary you're
gonna have to commit to being honest
with him
and not lobbing grenades and can we be
honest you could throw some grenades
can't you you know how to hurt James
right
yeah I do and you've never done that
before have you
yes you have yes you have
and James
you're gonna have to commit to getting
well for you
yes sir and then you're able to show up
with Mary now let's let's not walk away
here with any like rose-colored glasses
she said right now I'm not interested in
a romantic relationship with James James
I want you to hear that that's hard to
hear okay it is you said you said the
words I don't want to lose my wife she's
telling you
I'm I've stepped out okay and so we're
not trying to get back what was we're
trying to build something completely new
Mary are are you do you feel unsafe
going to coffee
no I don't um we actually tried dinner a
couple days ago and like I told
him let's try something new let's be
friends let's get to know each other
again and that's you know okay if any of
this can go anywhere you know and James
I think that's a really wise Place
starting with not
hey how do we uh how do I get you how do
I get you back how do we get let's just
instead of starting there I think we
start with hey my name is James
and uh I have a couple of kids and I
have this woman that I'm madly in love
with that I man one time I said I
screwed it up you want to hear that
story
and she can say hi my name is Mary and
I've been through a lot
and uh
I'd love to meet you I'd love to get to
know you a little bit better let's start
there
it's gonna be hard to take the pressure
off because you all do have history
together you got life together but let's
start there
let's start communicating with our big
friends let's start connecting I don't
even say starting to woo or date but I
don't even know if Mary if you're there
yet if you're not that's great you get
to have that choice
and James here's a hard hard thing last
hard thing
this one may be done
and let's get to the worst case scenario
this if this is done your relationship
with Mary is over your friendship's not
your co-parenting is not but you're
you're dating relationship your romantic
relationship with Mary's over
you're still worth a peaceful life
you're still worth being well
and you're still worthy of being loved
[Music]
continue the journey you started my
brother I'm proud of Mary continue
honoring your body and your own safety
and man
I can't wait to hear what happens next
with you two so keep me in the loop I'm
grateful for you all for calling and
sharing your story
um and from this point forward
we never cheat again right good we'll be
right back
[Music]
I've got a word from our sponsor better
help listen I've been on both ends of
therapy in my life I've gotten it myself
and I've walked people through it and
I've seen the benefits from both sides
when someone owns their past and the
cracks in their armor but here's the
deal Getting to Know Yourself is not a
one-time event acknowledging the stories
that make you who you are can be a
lifelong process and talking through
things with the right sounding board
empowers you to change your future and
be the best version of yourself so if
you're thinking about starting therapy I
recommend better help better help
connect you with a licensed therapist
who can walk with you on that journey of
self-discovery and it's a hundred
percent online and it's designed to be
convenient flexible and work for your
schedule just fill out a quick
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and if it's not the
right fit you can switch therapists at
any time for no additional charge visit
betterhelp.com deloney today to get 10
off your first month that's betterhelp
h-e-l-p.com
deloney
all right we are back let's go to Daniel
in Cincinnati what's up Daniel
good afternoon sir how are you
outstanding my brother how are you
oh not too bad a little nervous I don't
be nervous it's all good man what's up
oh watch one of um apologize in advance
when I get nervous or anxious I'd stop
them all over my words and sometimes my
train of thought deviate so hey uh
Tomball I apologize in advance have you
ever listened to this show
I have and it makes me feel a little
better but I Stumble over everything
with me on the show I Stumble over
everything not because I'm anxious I
just can't speak properly uh but hey
thank you for for being brave and
calling it anyway even though this is a
terrifying proposition for you I'm
grateful for you so what's up man
life has happened since I made the email
to uh to your booth crew um the original
question was how I can handle anxiety
around
uh unlike whenever I see news or things
happening in the world or
just I mean kind of referencing how what
you've struggled with when you just
think like what's gonna happen when it
all falls apart want it all it's the fan
how am I going to provide for my family
how am I going to provide for like work
what if I lose work and the nerd word
the nerd word for that is
catastrophizing there you go okay all
right so that was your original that was
originally why you called in
that
but I'm
wondering if it is just possibly a
symptom of like a bigger anxiety or just
something more because
I get hit with that catastrophizing
at different times and then it just
throws me for days or sometimes a day
but I kind of have to like bury my head
and all have to like listen to
audiobooks or podcasts or I kind of have
to like
I don't know if I'm making myself forget
it or I just wind myself down from the
initial build up so can I can I use can
I use your situation as a teaching
moment for everybody listening because I
think it can be a great gift to folks
yes but only
um I'm gonna walk through with you a
series of questions I think your your
impulse is absolutely correct okay
um barring some sort of
um brain lesions and things which are
super super super rare I think your
impulse is very correct
um so I'm gonna go through a series of
questions that I normally ask folks who
are struggling with anxiety these are
the questions I ask myself okay
okay um
none of these questions are judgment
questions okay so
um
the only way to get to like some truth
is you just to just say it as quick as
you can and as honest as you can cool
same team
yep all right so
overall weight and health how are we
doing
good good
you exercise regularly you sleep okay
um you're not
you're not super overweight
no not overweight I'm pretty active in
my job I do construction carpentry
excellent says sleeping is as good as we
can as good as I can do I've got some
younger kids that okay wake up from time
to time but I'd say overall sleep well
yeah all right how much how much money
do you owe other people how much debt do
you carry
uh 20 like if you just a grand or so
okay that's credit cards how about your
house
it's just uh just house and a little bit
of personal loan to a family member
how much in your house
uh
throughout 20 or just reload low 20s
around 20. so you'll have your house
paid off with 20 grand
yes wow we are we are running towards
that as as fast as we are able all right
in-laws
do they run your life or they are you
pretty connected
oh real very connected very yeah okay
very connected very close what about
your folks
uh same very connected very close uh
would not be where I am in life without
either set of in-laws or parents
excellent friends do you have a group of
guys that you do life with you hang out
with outside of work
working working towards that that's been
something I've been trying to think last
month or so you guys
meeting with two individual two older
gentlemen uh from church that I respect
and then I have a couple of friends that
um I would get together whenever we can
so no
in your dream in your dream world yes
but in reality no I've got some guys
that I work with on job sites and then I
come home to a wife and some young kids
yes okay all right cool
um what about things the nerd word here
is anxiogenic so tell me about your how
much coffee Red Bull how much caffeine
do you in you take
um I'll have a couple of tumblers
through the morning or the Working Day
and then past that just some just tea
and water in the evenings okay all right
um tell me about your marriage how y'all
doing
highs and lows but overall that's so not
great so tell me about it
I would lean toward great there's just
we're trying to work through raising
kids uh we had an idea of what how we
would parent but that's the that's the
Newlywed idea of it but other than that
I think that's the biggest stressor is
just learning how to raise kids and live
live life okay
um
how many kids do you have
three with a planned one in this fall
okay and what's what are their ages
uh five three and almost two oh good
grief okay next time you talk to
somebody about anxiety lead with that
okay
that you have a three wild animals that
live inside your house
um okay
um tell me about
childhood trauma any stuff lingering any
things that were tough growing up
um before listening to your show I would
have said no trauma but
um I'm starting to wonder if I need to
come learning to redefine that word
um growing up I mean things were great
um
money was tight at times
um but we my parents were very diligent
and gave us a great a great life growing
up
um
my parents came to came to faith when I
was young and so my early years were
kind of I have memories of
them kind of working out how to live
life and how to do that in a
um
in a faith-base we started going to
church and I think there was some
kind of the pendulum swinging of
learning through that
um that maybe there may be a little bit
there but again I'm just kind of
starting to starting to look at that
through the lens of
what could that have Are you a
this is gonna sound like a loaded
question and just just be honest with me
okay
are you someone who has almost a
supernatural ability to
compartmentalize things that disappoint
you or hurt your feelings or hurt you in
order of making sure everybody else
keeps their reputation and everything
looks good
Maybe
try again
I'm not sure let's put it that way okay
all right
um some people
not a ton of them but some people had
incredibly smooth lives
just had no bricks in the backpack man
and some of them then moved up to be
adults and ended up with a pretty great
life
and they're a they have a pretty great
marriage and they got the chaos of three
young kids and that's life
um but they kept plugging along and they
paid their house off while they were
still really young so they didn't even
have that stress anymore that happened
more common and again I don't want to
create problems where they don't exist
okay so this could be you and that is
man um high five
and
there is an intense pressure on millions
and millions of people
to be peacekeepers and image bearers
and
there is a deep-seated it feels like a
deep betrayal to talk bad about somebody
or to tell the truth about a situation
or to be honest about just how hard or
negative or how how much you're
struggling with something
and as the great vessel Vandercook says
your body's keeping the score
and so it could be you know we just
adjusted with the pendulum as as we were
kids
and it could have been
screaming knock down drag out fights or
things that we used to do all of a
sudden we couldn't and parents looked at
you and said do you want to burn in hell
forever right so
there's one way of telling that story
then there's another way of telling that
story and it may have just been nah man
my parents decided to start going to
church and they decided that they were
going to start living this way and there
was a natural clunkiness to figuring out
how that works but that's that's normal
I don't want to put stories in your in
your head that don't work your language
sounds very careful to me
yes okay and sometimes very very careful
language very calculated language is
language is a way of speaking that
somebody has had to adapt and develop to
keep themselves safe
and if that I would agree with that if
that's you
that's anxiety
that is a body underneath that like
there will not be any ripples in this
water
and that is a body underneath that water
struggling for air
see what I'm saying
yeah so you can go back over those
things I just talked through
and say okay where am I struggling to
say I'm really mad
or I'm really scared real scared
or this isn't what I had in mind or I
miss my wife
or quite honestly my parents provided
for us and they were tough to be around
they weren't abusive I don't want to use
that word it was just really hard to be
around and I don't feel safe going to
them for stuff and I'm pretty lonely see
what I'm saying
there's a uh the first step in in
healing from an anxious life is owning
reality choosing reality this is the
truth about my life
okay and so we don't have to do that on
this call but I think that's an
important place to start uh my friend
will godera he's a um a restaurant here
one of the best on the planet in New
York
I love what he tells his weight staff
he says you can only fill other people's
picture
when yours is full
okay and so what he's telling his staff
is you guys got to go do the hard work
of filling your picture up so that you
can show up for these customers who come
to our restaurant I want to take that
analogy and and
completely reverse it for anxiety
if you have an anxious life if you've
got a bunch of stuff going on or a bunch
of unspoken things that you haven't
fully connected
your body is going to be at capacity
that pitcher is going to be completely
full
and then you throw on top of it we're
going to war with China we're going to
war with Russia world war three is
happening we're gonna have food and
climate shortages we're going to all
stuff your body's anywhere else for that
stuff to go
you see what I'm saying
yeah and so then you have to get into a
cycle of avoidance I'm just gonna not
watch this stuff
until the water stops trickling into
your already overfilled pitcher
and so the question I want to ask you is
where do you have
what you're describing to me is someone
who's created a very anxious life that
then when what I call normal stressors
there will always be wars and rumors of
wars when those things show up they
become overwhelming they override the
system
so going back and choosing reality where
is a place
that you're you've filled this sucker up
probably a lot of places because
as you've been laying it out it's just
things just keep coming to mind okay oh
all right oh oh I mean like I do
um I've explained yeah just say it just
say it just say it just try to tell it
to my wife like I bottle things up yes
and then it either has to come out or it
boils over and but I just yeah there's
just I just find it really hard to open
up and talk to people about anything and
then like you said I'm
being careful with my words to keep
everything happy and hunky-dory and that
makes it difficult to have hard
conversations and also it also makes it
very hard to be married to
and it makes it very hard and I'm not
shaming you I'm just I I want you to see
the dance that happens
when somebody walks up and feels like
they're talking to somebody's Twitter
account
it's hard to plug into that with true
connection
and when somebody's married to somebody
who is just basically a screen saver
with how wonderful things are
they feel crazy
because things aren't wonderful
and then they withdraw a little bit
and then the person behind the screen
saver's body is screaming whoa connect
connect but it can't get through the
screen saver
and you see how it just creates a dance
and then that person gets a little bit
closer than that other person pulls
further away and now we're in a kind of
a mess
see what I'm saying
yeah and so here's the the beautiful
thing that you're dealing with is
there's not any wild overt Madness
the challenging part for you is
I was making a salary that my granddad
couldn't have wrapped his head around
and so was my wife and we were married
and we were paying off six figures of
debt and we had a two-year-old little
boy after years of infertility and I
went mad
I went mad with work expectations I went
mad with dreams of what things were
gonna be like one day I went mad with I
was sharing a bed with somebody that I
know loved me but I was incredibly alone
I was paying off all this debt but my
body kept asking for what what are we
doing
like what okay so we pay off our house
then what right you see what I'm saying
and it just their alarms the anxiety
alarms kept getting louder and louder
and louder and louder
and my dad was a cop and a minister you
talk about good at wallpaper language I
was one of the best
you hear what I'm do you hear you hear
it so I do here's the here's what I I
wouldn't do a couple of things
and it's gonna sound like a like a weird
twist I'm gonna send you
all of the ones I have all the the
couples ones the dating ones and the kid
ones the questions for humans
oh man thank you you don't have to do
that thank you well it's I love you and
I'm I'm grateful for your bravery
I want you to start using these cards to
have no
um
uh just just
no expectation conversations with people
that you love
I'm gonna send you the guys nights out
and you can just have some buddies over
and y'all can do whatever watch the game
watch football watch fights whatever it
is y'all do I don't know you can go
build cabinets or I don't know you sound
like like a guy knows how to do stuff
um or y'all can just sit around have
chips and queso and
I I don't know I play play Texas Hold'em
and use these cards
but I want you to start practicing human
connection okay
then I want you to take a piece of paper
and I want you to write down things that
you do not fee where you do not places
where you do not feel safe
and be honest and then be very clear
about what I can control and what I
cannot control you cannot control
whether China's sins missiles to Russia
and escalates this thing into World War
Three you can
you can't control whether China invades
Taiwan you can't
you can't control whether Biden does
whatever and then whoever gets elected
after him gets does whatever you can't
control any of those things
and there's something powerful about
letting your brain know yeah these are
happening and we can't do anything about
it and literally after a season of
practice your brain will begin to create
a gap between oh we gotta do something
and oh that's not our problem to solve
because we can't and then it won't sound
the alarm so much anymore
see what I'm saying
yeah so does the piece I guess that's
kind of one of the reasons I was calling
was just how do I find peace and not not
the stress of it just is does the time
of
after those alarms quiet does this the
piece of knowing like oh what's I mean
what's I can't control it and the
outcome may not be may not be great but
I can't control it is that where the
beginning of the piece comes from the
beginning of the piece is this when your
body starts to feel anxious you ask
yourself body what are you trying to
protect me from oh Russia we can't do
anything about that one
and then you let that like literally
feel it run through your body can't do
anything about it and so
continuing just to scroll on the news
sites tell me how it's all coming down
we're all gonna die and blah I kid I
can't I'm just gonna turn that off
because that's not helpful that's just
gearing me up and gearing me up and
gearing me up and gearing me up
now if an invasion happens
I'm gonna stay glued to the radio
because I want to know where the bombs
are falling
that's not our world right now
once I know that inflation's high and I
go to the grocery store I can see those
prices they're expensive
I'm done with the inflation conversation
because the only thing I can control is
my budget how much money I'm bringing
into my house and the choices me and my
wife make about what we buy and don't
buy that's what I can control
not how much bacon is not how much
cereal is or whatever see what I'm
saying so the piece comes from
disconnecting from I've got to be in
charge and control everything
and instead it's about
I've got to get connected
I've got to take care of my body
I've got to be very intentional about
where I'm not safe
and I've got to focus on the things I
can control versus the things I can't
control
and I want you to be really really
graceful with Daniel because Daniel's a
good good guy he's a great husband he's
a good dad
he's a great provider he's doing good
things for his community
and he's learning to live in a new body
a body that's a father of three going on
four a body who's married to a woman who
he loves desperately and they've never
been married with three kids almost four
before
it's all new we're all learning
I'm gonna be really graceful with our
bodies I'm also going to send you a copy
of own your past change your future I
want you to go through that book and
check out some of the stories you may be
hanging on to that you've learned over
the years to talk really eloquently
about
but that may be spinning your body up
Amazon your copy of redefining anxiety
just a quick read to read through it and
um
uh just know this I'm really grateful
for your call
you're looking at a guy who's been there
and on the other side of it there is
peace there's peace
our practicing start building a
non-anxious life we'll be right back
hey good folks John deloney here I feel
like I fell through a glitch in The
Matrix this is my job I get to have this
show do this show walk alongside each
one of you as a career this is what I do
and I have a blast doing it and me and
the team were so thankful for all of you
for being a part of our show whether
you're one of the original 17 or you're
one of the millions that's come since
then we are so grateful for you and we
want to put together the best possible
show that we can so if you're one of The
Originals or if you're brand new we want
your feedback tell us what you love
about the show what you hate about the
show would you like to see more of would
you like to hear more of and what you
want us to never do again you can email
us at askjohn ramseysolutions.com that's
ask John
ramseysolutions.com with your feedback
thank you for being such an important
part of the show rock on
all right let's take one more let's go
to Ashley in Pittsburgh hey Ashley
what's up
you're taking my call I'm fantastic how
are you
all right so what's up
I have quite the Dizzy for you so I was
watching your show and I was watching
your show and I have recently been
having
an issue with my mother-in-law and I can
say it's recent but it actually has been
going on for quite some time so we my
husband and I just welcomed the daughter
and she's five weeks old congratulations
thank you and whenever we go to visit
family we don't go to visit my
mother-in-law and my father-in-law and
that's due to I mean just to get right
into it
um my mother-in-law she has been
suffering from anxiety and depression
evidently for like 25 years and and the
time that I've been in the family like
seven years later I've really watched it
escalate and
it's really tough and I'm this is a
tough situation for the whole family
because it's one of those things that
nobody is
nobody's been able to put their thumb on
why we can't
um why we can't help some of these some
of the things that she's been uh that
have been affecting the rest of us so
really what my question is is we we
don't go over to visit because her house
is absolutely filthy and my
father-in-law he doesn't he's I think
that he's just exhausted and there's
nothing that he's been able to do to
um to get a hold of it or try to better
the situation and she also smokes in the
home and I just had an appointment for
my daughter like a week ago and the
doctor asked does she is she exposed to
secondhand smoke and I said no but
that's because we don't go over to visit
but this whole Myriad of issues has
driven a little bit of a wedge between
me and my mother-in-law because I just
won't take her over to their house
instead
let's reframe that okay
is that cool okay I want to reframe this
whole conversation
um
the rift in in the family
is not because of your mother-in-law
the rift in your family is because your
family and probably your husband's
family
um
is trying to solve problems that's the
person with the challenges is not asking
them to solve and really has no interest
in changing
and so what's happening is a whole bunch
of people are making themselves crazy
trying to fix a problem that the person
who's experiencing it doesn't want fixed
man I've pulled out all the stops I've
done everything I can do there's no stop
here's the one thing you haven't done
the only thing that that matters here
and that is look that sweet little baby
girl in the eye and say I've got one job
and that's to the best of my ability to
keep you safe
not keep you yeah infinitely protected
from scraping your little knee and
getting in trouble and getting dumped
that's life
but I'm talking about from things that
are going to harm you
and sending your kid to somebody who's
not well
in a home full of smoke
in a home that you've described as
unsanitary is not safe
yeah and so
because your mother-in-law is either
unable to or is not interested in
doing this hard hard hard stuff she
would need to do to get well
she by proxy is choosing to not see that
little girl
it's as simple as that
and to my colleagues who would say well
she can't make that choice because she's
struggling with X Y and Z that's fine
too I'm this isn't a blaming
conversation this is just laying out the
facts
whether she's choosing to not get well I
don't think anybody's choosing to be
anxious I don't think anybody chooses to
be a hoarder or a living filth I don't
think that's a choice I think I'm
choosing to not get well right that's a
byproduct or they can't make that choice
and it just is either way I'm not
putting my kid in that situation
right okay so that's where I struggle
because I want to help and I've done
everything I can would you recommend any
I would recommend that you detox I can
read about nope I would detox you got a
detox from being a people pleaser
and you have to detox from being I'm
freaking Ashley from Pittsburgh and I'm
in control of everything no you're not
so detox
I'm in control of everything in my own
little world because you just had a baby
and you are not and that's gonna make
you mad and not mad like angry but mad
insane
yeah because you could control it all
until baby came and then you have those
moments that you realize some you think
back to some of the dates you've been on
and you think back to some of the things
that people told you on the school bus
and there's that moment that all new
parents have I have them and by the way
it's not just new parents it's when our
kids go to different stages like when my
kid went to middle school I thought back
to the things I was a part of and things
that happened to me in middle school and
I got sick through my stomach like I got
like I got literally ill
I thought of the things I said to
little kids when I was in elementary
school when I was in Middle School I was
mean
and I have a seven-year-old daughter and
it makes me ill like to my stomach to
know that there's gonna be people like
me around her
I can get choked up saying it if I'm not
careful
and this is the part where love gets
really scary
and most of us when things get scary we
tighten our grip around the wheel
and it doesn't help anything
sometimes the greatest gift is to loosen
our grip on that wheel that makes sense
yeah so don't get your esteem and don't
get your value and don't take your angst
out on trying to fix your mother-in-law
she has not invited you into that
conversation she hasn't asked for your
help she doesn't want to be less anxious
she doesn't want to whatever but she has
asked for my help okay and I've done
everything I can and that's where I'm
I and I feel like I've done I've done
reading and yeah I've this is about
other people with this and at the risk
of sounding ignorant towards anxiety and
depression I don't experience it but I
this she's evidently she's been battling
this and has been to so many doctors and
has been on countless medications which
scares me because when you're switching
medications constantly that can't be
good for her brain
and I think to the future and I'm like
what yeah yeah what I mean but again but
then it goes back to what you said with
you can't control that she doesn't want
to get better right and so here's the
deal she might say the words I want your
help
and if you've listened to this show for
more than a couple of episodes I always
probably say it too much behavior is a
language
so I can tell my wife I want to be a
better husband I want to be a better
husband and then I never help with the
dishes I don't want to be a better
husband no matter what I'm saying
because my actions are speaking very
loudly
and I can say I don't want to be
depressed I don't want to be anxious
anymore I'm tired of feeling anxious all
the time
and my actions say well I'm not going to
call a counselor
I'm not going to start hanging out with
people and get some community in my life
I'm not going to start eating well and
taking care of my body I'm not gonna do
that
well behavior is a language
I'm gonna write that down that's some
good stuff but but here's the deal
um don't go to war with it open your
hands up it just it's an is
yeah and know this that when I I
I've got two competing rules and they
often intersect and they don't know the
two rules of life
um or two of many rules of life I have
number one is I don't speak to just have
said something that's our instagrammy
world like people are always asking why
didn't you comment on this and why don't
you comment on that because I don't have
anything to add to the noise
and they just people people don't want
to know what I have to think about
things they just want to see if I'm on
their team about a thing so that's
number one I only speak if I can
actually be heard
the second thing is
um
I don't let
I I I let me say it this way it's cruel
to put up boundaries and not let people
know that there's a boundary there
and they're just running in and they
also They smash into something they
didn't know was there
and I get that with your mother-in-law
she may not be able to hear it if you
sit down and say I love you so much and
I'm so grateful for you I'm not
comfortable nothing to do with her I'm
not comfortable bringing my kid into a
house where somebody smokes inside
I'm not comfortable bringing my kid into
this house
because as we have talked about it's
really unsanitary
I'll be with you if you ask for my help
you want to clean the sucker up and all
that I'm all in but right now I'm making
this choice
am I a bad person if I've thrown in the
towel on trying to help in multiple ways
because I've been there to help clean no
and no because I'm just exhausted no
you're not a bad person like the rest of
the family and that's where I have a
hard time like man she's 50. and is this
just how life's gonna be and we're just
gonna
own reality well I guess we are just
choose reality
it is what is there it is what it is I
choose reality and I mean I wouldn't do
this show if I didn't believe deeply
that
man I just seen people come back from
the brink in all all different ages all
different situations all different like
from the wildest trauma to
you know 60 and 70 year old saying I'm
just gonna be different now
um and they just choose a different pest
so I'm in this for the Long Haul I I I I
don't believe in quote unquote giving up
on somebody I also
believe in living in reality so you've
been there a bunch you've tried to clean
up a bunch it has not worked great
I'm gonna stop expending energy all the
time trying to solve that problem and
quite frankly that exhaustion you feel
is probably you on the treadmill
you're not going anywhere it's running
really hard
if there comes a moment when she says
I'm ready finally I'm ready ready
seeing a counselor I'm meeting with my
doctor to get some stability here
I want to start doing regular lunches or
breakfast or whatever once a week with
so and so and fill in the blank here
we're gonna we're gonna set up a pattern
we're gonna set up a life
um you're gonna find you have a lot more
energy because you haven't been just
sprinting and sprinting and sprinting
and getting nowhere right but no don't
ever apologize especially as a mom of a
five week old or five bundle
for not having energy
you get you get a moment you get a
moment and particularly do not apologize
for your boundaries it's a conversation
for you and
your spouse to sit down and say okay uh
what boundaries do we want to have for
this little one and we have to be on the
same page as we move forward
we're gonna be eating this together
congratulations on having a little baby
I wish it was different I know that's
not how you envisioned this thing going
I know that
I'm sorry
the only thing you can handle
is what comes next only you can deal
with is what comes next
can't wait to see what happens we'll be
right back
it seems so easy but most of us way
undervalue real genuine relationships
our friendships our marriages we don't
know what we're doing and instead of
diving into the mess we accept
shallowness and distraction and we
wallpaper over our loneliness so let me
say this boldly you cannot be well alone
you've got to get connected to real life
people and have deep powerful
relationships I'm talking about
relationships where you can be honest
where you can open up where you can
share hard things and you each know that
you'll still show up for each other and
in my new book own your past change your
future we'll walk through a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness and getting
connected is a key part of that that's
why you'll learn shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous and more
importantly you'll learn how to create
meaningful relationships in your life
moving forward there is no good app to
help adults find friendships but this
book can help go to John deloney.com to
take the next step towards Wellness
that's own your past change your future
at John deloney.com
all right we are back and I was just
asking Kelly I don't know if we're even
allowed to do Michael Jackson yes we are
Michael Jackson with the classic I'm
talking about the man in the mirror I'm
gonna make a change for once in my life
it's gonna feel real good Gonna Make a
Difference gonna make it right
as I turn up the collar on my favorite
winter coat man Kelly is always popping
that collar this wind is blowing my mind
I see kids in the street with not enough
to eat who am I to be blind pretending
not to see their needs a summer's
disregard a broken bottle top and one
man's Soul they follow each other on the
win you know because they got nowhere to
go that's why I want you to know I'm
starting with the man in the mirror I'm
starting with a minute I love you guys
stand school don't do drugs
[Music]